what up reject Nation it's your girl
salamander AKA Sally Lamonica you can
follow me on all socials welcome back we
are on Thor 2 the Dark World I don't
know anything about it so I'm going into
it with a fresh mind please hit that
like button if you do enjoy this
reaction at any point if I make you
laugh it would make you cry hopefully
it'll make you cry also please hit that
subscribe button if you're not already
subscribed because I don't know you like
should be it's free and not a lot of
things in this world are free I'm pretty
sure in the dark world it's not free to
subscribe
so see what I did there if you want to
watch my full reaction to this movie you
can go to the patreon of the real
rejects it's
www.patreon.com the real rejects Greg
and John have a bunch of other really
fun full-length reactions and cool stuff
for you guys on that channel also we
have merch now there is real rejects
merch I'm pretty sure it's going to be
in the link below get you a hoodie or a
beanie it really helps the channel and
quick shout out to prepper for editing
together these highlights y'all are real
ones I'm so excited all right we are
descending to the Chrome in three two
ow I'm such a dork and I hate it and
this is why I was in popular in high
school
an ancient force of infinite destruction
Venom
as the nine words
could at last unleash the ether
But as God ripped the weapon from his
grasp without it the dark elves fell
oh I hate that my ass that's creepy
shall we destroy it
if only we could
cook One does not simply walk into more
doors the one will ever find it
but someone's gonna find it
plot twist wherever you go there is war
ruin all this because low-key desires
it is my Birthright yeah Birthright
what's that guy
who spend the rest of your days in the
dungeon forever why do I still feel bad
for Loki
there he is
I've got this completely under control
is that why everything's on fire that's
cause a girl was leading it of course
everything's gonna be on fire
have you seen our emotions
all yours
I'd love to see him in the hall fight
I accept your surrender
[Applause]
[Music]
you are ready time has come for you to
take the throat Embrace and celebrate
what you've won at least pretend to
enjoy yourself
oh he misses her
boy she misses you too don't even worry
about it you know that scientific
equipment you're gonna look at anymore
you might want to start looking at it
again this is the reason we came all the
way out here kind of looks like the
readings that Eric was rambling about I
want banana balls he's not interested
I'm not interested
harmless Rambler approached the area
then decided to strip naked and
effectively terrorize tourists there
with scientific equipment while shouting
that he was trying to save them the man
later identified as noted astrophysicist
oh no
oh they're kids
are you the police
no we're a scientists well I am
where'd it go
Sometimes they come back sometimes they
don't
I was gonna be like jump now I'm like no
car keys
why would you do that
what
it's like the upside down
what
I knew it
I was like is he gonna say
it has awoken but he's had something
similar
how do they always know they're always
sleeping and it's always like
it's like that's a raven they just know
how was she
clever your motor
she doesn't know it yet but she studies
the convergence as well
even
what
hmm
where the hell were you tell me you
didn't call the police you were gone for
five hours
what
that's weird
whoa
oh my God he's there
imagine waking up from a nap and he's
just standing there and you're like oh
my God
that's cool you said you were coming
back I know I know but the bifrost was
destroyed the nine Realms erupted to the
chaos wards where raging Marauders were
pillaging I had to put an end of the
slaughter imagine that's what your
boyfriend sends you after ghosting you
the realms
his private property and your
trespassing a lot of them you have to
come with me
this woman has done well she's dangerous
so am I
hold on to me what are you doing
go into space
oh [ __ ]
I would vomit probably
[Laughter]
I don't know whether to laugh
the infection
defending born of Eternal knife the dark
elves come to steal away the light made
a weapon out of that darkness and it was
called The Ether The Ether is fluid and
ever-changing it changes matter into
dark matter it seeks out host bodies
drawing strength from their life force
malakive sought to use the ether's power
to turn the universe their masks are so
creepy
does your book happen to mention how to
get it out of me
no has no one asked her like how it got
in her yet
a true king admits his faults what if
the lives you took on Earth I mean a
handful compared to the number that Odin
has taken himself
your father he's not my father
three five thousand years the world's
aligned perfectly the borders between
worlds become blood
it's possible you found one of these
points
once the world's pass
out of the moment
when the connection is lost
she just so happened to fall through a
portal
to happen to be where the ether is or
they're supposedly supposed to have
buried it so no one would find it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you might want to take the stairs to the
left what
nothing severe you've never been a very
good liar
take it to your Chambers I'll come for
you when it's safe
she's like she's leopard
dang what is this dagger made out of
what
day
good job Idris Elba
wow
[Music]
everybody
's gonna get through
[Music]
how did he know where that was
foreign
which so sorry
where is these
I'll never tell I believe you
no
[Applause]
dude she was badass I'm sad
[Music]
and the last thing Loki said to her was
you're not my mother oh my God
I'm having a moment
I hope Loki gets revenge
because he's gonna feel really guilty
[Music]
I don't know about her I'd be feeling
real upset that
Thor's mom got killed by protecting me
because I'm an idiot and touched
thing I don't know I would feel so
guilty
you should too
we better fight
the last house Guardian breath
the last drop of us got in blood and how
are you different from Malika the
difference my son is that I will win
he being mad
we must move Jane off world
my Frost has been shut down and the
Tesseract locked away in the vault
there are other parts of ashgard
ing to a few one actually
oh
have you come to gloat you're enough
no more illusions
[Music]
thank God
I know you seek Vengeance as much as I
do
you helped me escape as God and I will
granted to you
you must be truly desperate
know that when we fought each other in
the past
I did so with a glimmer of hope that my
brother must have been there somewhere
that hope no longer exists to protect
you
you betrayed me and I will kill you
hmm Brother you look ravishing it will
hurt no less when I kill you in this
form perhaps you prefer one of your new
companions given that you seem to like
them so much oh this is much better
feel the righteousness surging hey wanna
have a rousing discussion about truth
honor patriotism God bless him
[Laughter]
he's loving this it's so good
yeah
I'm Loki
that was for New York
I like her
well whatever you're doing brother I
suggest you do it faster shut up looky
must have missed something I didn't I'm
pressing every button on this thing
laughs
foreign
now they're following us
well done you just decapitated your
grandfather
let's steal the biggest most obvious
ship in the universe and escaping that
it's truly brilliant
laughs
I see your time in the dungeons has made
you no less graceful Loki okay I was
like
how are you gonna get there in the water
everyone would do it are you mad
possibly
foreign
Josh
get your hand on me and Josh
but I thought you still wanted to kill
that as Guardians because you hate them
you think you alone were loved a mother
you had her tricks but I had her trust
trust we let her die what help were you
and yourself who put me that who brought
me that you looked down the world
you wouldn't want us to fight
or she wouldn't exactly be shocked
look
where'd they go
still don't trust me brother
would you
no I wouldn't what
whoa
damn she's tripping
[Music]
now
wow
wait what
[Music]
ah
yeah you smell completely horrible that
twist though okay
I'm here for it I liked that
[Music]
no no no no no no
okay good
job Dora
oh
um
that'll do it
no
see you in hell monster
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry I'm sorry
it's all right
I'll tell father what you did here today
no I like Mommy I didn't do it for him
God damn it
I don't want to watch these anymore
I saw him on Earth
why would he go to Earth
none of this would have happened if I
hadn't found the answer
would have only possessed that much
sooner
this is why you don't chase after men
destroy the planet I would be a little
more upset that your brother just died
Thor oh my God I was just wondering if
you want to try again uh maybe dinner
next time oh yeah yeah yeah oh my God
oh those are the keys so who's Richard
really
oh this movie
malachith is going to fire The Ether at
a spot where all the nine worlds are
connecting yeah so the alignment is only
temporary he must be in exactly the
right place at the right time well how
do we know where that is
follow the directions
foreign
your world and your family will be
extinguished
uh
it is awesome how did you do that well
gravitational fields interact with the
weak spots between worlds creating right
get the guy with the sword
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that's crazy
what
this Amber was like nope
oh
that noise killed me
they're like standing inside you just
hear oh
oh man they got me wow
oh my God
she's
okay
go Ian do something heroic
yes
[Applause]
you saved my life yes I did
KSM
[Laughter]
how do I get to Greenwich
take the strain three stops
[Music]
that's crazy you're telling no one else
notices that
those things stopping you not from here
we can't get close enough
he needs some goggles
I've come to accept your surrender
[Music]
the evil cannot be destroyed
but you can
[Music]
where did he go
that's lucky
I'd rather be a good man than a great
king
is this my son I hear
or the woman he loves
um
this is not for Jane father now forbid
me to see her or say she can rule on my
side it changes nothing
one son who wanted the throne too much
another who will not take it
I cannot give you my blessing
nor can I wish you good fortune if I
were proud of the man my son had become
even that I could not say go
my son
thank you Father
no
thank you what
oh I was wondering why they didn't
spend more time on the grief of his
death and oh my God what
I almost cried over you okay
I'm gonna skip to the end credits now
Let's uh skip on down
Loki needs to stop playing games man
here's Thunder
oh no oh
my God
Thor will return
well that was Thor the Dark World listen
guys I didn't hate it as much as I
thought I would pissed off other people
saying it was like one of the worst ones
I would say I really enjoyed the second
half way more than I enjoyed the first
half I feel like it kind of reminded me
of watching a show there was lots of
repetitive scenes I don't know if it was
just me that noticed that like they
showed the scientists running around
naked like twice
um I feel like that could have just been
one they basically kept having the same
conversations over and over I was like
is this risky what do we do and then
also like oh let's tell the story I told
you as a kid but it was true stuff like
that I feel like it could have been
condensed a little bit they didn't
really give the audience the benefit of
the doubt with that one because they
already explained in the beginning I was
like okay cool I get it you're setting
up the villain now oh this thing
happened a long time ago and you need to
know this information because it comes
back later you know these people come
back for Revenge I get that there was
just a lot of repetitive conversations
so I can understand why people thought
this movie was slow only because like
the first half of it kind of felt like
that I feel like a show where they were
spending a little more time I felt like
I watched like three episodes of like
kidnap book show or something but I
definitely enjoyed seeing Jane's
character a lot more in this movie
because she got a lot of moments in this
movie to shine grieving over two
characters in one movie
it was a lot but I I understand why they
did that and I was so upset when she
died she's such an amazing actress the
mother I thought her performance when
she had that really heart-wrenching
argument was low-key it was just awful
she did such a good job with that
because then with her death it like
really showed some weight I feel like
though in terms of Jane and Thor
I don't think it lingered a lot on their
grief at all of like anything and I kind
of wish it did this could have been way
darker with I don't know maybe diving
into Thor's just it's kind of again
reminding me of like
Spider-Man 2 when he's like I don't even
think this is something I want to do
anymore because it's just hurting people
around me and I think that would be so
brilliant because it really delves deep
into the characters constant battle
within himself of is this the
responsibility that I really want and I
feel like by the end of it went Thor's
like I don't want to be king I feel like
it would have been more impactful if you
really you saw him really mentally
struggle after the death of his mom and
then after the death of his brother like
he should have been out for the count
like mentally just a wreck right but
then there was just a lot of humor which
I loved all the humor in this movie but
something about it didn't seem very
human to me to just jump from both of
those and then but then you see Loki at
them that kind of pissed me off
it kind of pissed me off
another twist I get it but like they
should have ended it there and I feel
like the twist maybe could have been I'm
mad
I don't know that was a lot that was a
lot I I'm processing a lot would have
been more powerful if you walked away
from the movie being like Loki's dad
holy [ __ ] you know because then if you
came back later
I don't know anything about the rest of
the movie is really but I know there's
another Avengers like let's say he came
back then you'd be like what the [ __ ]
bro explain but it would have held more
weight
I just want things to hold more weight
with these Marvel movies man I do like
the amount of time they spent
um on the mom's you know passing that
that got me like that was impactful I
had tears in my eyes but yeah I just
kind of wanted to see more of Thor
really struggling with himself with this
movie and it didn't really happen I
wanted to see that struggle as the
character but um I I just still really
enjoyed watching the characters I I
enjoyed these characters a lot and that
little Cameo from Captain America killed
me oh my God that was really great that
was really great I think that Chris
Hemsworth and Tom Hiddleston play off
each other so well I love seeing their
Dynamic together which is why I was so
upset at the end
um the villain to me wasn't the most
interesting part of the movie to be
honest because you're kind of just like
okay how's Anna kill this guy and then
it was kind of Lucky it was just luck
basically they tell them if you really
think about it and then everything
falling that was a cool fight sequence
you know them just falling through
different Realms that was pretty sick
and made me laugh a lot I really enjoyed
watching that fight sequence because it
was unique in that sense I've never seen
a fighting games like that before but
yeah the villain wasn't
super interesting to me in this movie
and I feel like his motivation was just
I don't know it was pretty
one-dimensional to me but um overall the
I don't know the fighting and the
effects and everything were super sick
in this movie like so many different
aircrafts and ships and and weapons and
I just thought the the visual effects in
this movie were like amazing
um I I really enjoyed watching just all
the different like I could watch a show
of all these characters is what I'm
getting at like this I could watch more
of this not just as a movie I could
totally like see like an Asgard show or
something and I would be I would be into
it because this was like a mixture of
like Lord of the Rings in Star Wars
that's kind of in like a little bit of
Narnia I don't know that's what I was
thinking all throughout which is awesome
and you really got to see a lot more of
Kat Dennings character in this movie as
well and she's hilarious again kind of
the every man character which I
I would want to play a role like that so
bad it'll be so fun to be the comedic
relief in a movie like that I don't know
anything about the comics and in the
comments you can let me know is that in
the comics that Jane ends up getting the
was it called The Ether I just like
accidentally falling through into
another realm and then like seeing it
and like being like what is that that
seemed a little far-fetched to me it
would have been cooler if it happen a
different way I feel like but I don't
know if that was in the comics if that's
how it happened in the comics when I
think they buried it and like didn't
want anyone to find it I don't think
it'd be that easy it was my point of
like someone just fell through and like
there it is and it just happened to me
Jane I don't know but it was fun to see
all that go down and I really loved the
twist when you think that low-key top
door's arm off and was betraying his
brother that was so good I wanted to
laugh and then I didn't because then I
got real but like it's so funny to me
because the villains are just standing
there and there's kind of like
you know I can just see it from like an
outside perspective they're just in
there and they're like I'll do their
fighting right now like I was gonna see
what's going on and like they just they
want it in on the T right they was like
what what's the tea with the situation
let's go take a closer look on the drama
you know and then obviously it was part
of their plan but I just think it's
funny they were just like yeah let's go
over there and watch them like beat each
other
that was super fun I really I had fun
watching this movie it didn't take
itself too seriously but I feel like
some of the moments were deep enough
that you're you know I was really into
it if I were to re-watch this movie I'd
probably just watch like the second half
of it that's probably where other people
were coming from with it and in terms of
it being a little slow in the first half
but overall this was such a ride guys
this one had my emotions all over the
place more so than I think any of the
Marvel movies so far
so
I'm excited to see the rest because if
this is people's like on you know on the
lower end I can't imagine what's gonna
happen next in the future movies so I'm
super stoked also to see Robert Downey
Jr again and see them all interact again
and another Avengers movie with Thor and
everyone I guess Loki's back so
I don't know what he's gonna do but yeah
this was a ride thanks so much for
delving Into the Dark World with me I
can't say that normally I don't know why
and yeah again give this movie A like
hit subscribe and the next one's going
to be
Guardians
no the neck
and the next one is going to be Captain
America Winter Soldier which I have
heard nothing but good things about I'm
so excited to watch that movie so see
you next week bye
[Music]